il ya soir à la télévision alain juppé a
confirmé implicitement le refus du
gouvernement de renégocier la convention
le premier ministre qui déplore un
malentendu entre le gouvernement et les
internes a annoncé un nouvel effort
d'explication
les ministres concernés vont se rendre
sur le terrain hervé gaymard secrétaire
d'état à la santé a ainsi rencontré
aujourd'hui les internes du chu de tours
en grève depuis dix jours
reportage agnès money natalité bien
promettre la paix loin se rapprocher
pour que les internes et leurs ministres
puissent se parler il a fallu rapprocher
les tables à défaut de rapprocher les
points de vue les grévistes demandent
toujours la suppression d'un point
particulier de la convention médicale
celui qui prévoit que les médecins
doivent reverser de l'argent
les années où ils auront fait dépenser
plus que prévu à la sécurité sociale
ils ne veulent pas de ce système de
reversement pourquoi n'êtes vous pas
prêts à renégocier ce point particulier
et c'est ce qu'on vous demande avec tous
les représentants des différents
syndicats de médecins libéraux interne
chef de clinique et s'il vous plaît ne
nous répondait pas que c'est parce que
la convention est déjà signé parce que
ça nous le savons j'entends ce que vous
dites
ne croyez pas je vous le redis c'est
qu'il ne s'agit pas de sanction
collective
il ne s'agit pas de quotas date il
s'agit là c'est le savoyard qui parle
il s'agit en quelque sorte d'une corde
de rappel pour qu'on ait un système de
maîtrise crédibles ces fonds
l'explication aura duré deux heures
mais le ministre n'a pas réussi à
convaincre ni à faire comprendre nous a
expliqué cette façon de voir les choses
mais il ya de gros problèmes de
compréhension parce que même avec les
textes entre les mains il semble qu'on
ne comprenne pas la même chose c'est
incroyable ils se sont quittés autour
d'une collation pour autant ici à
l'hôpital trousseau de tours les
internes ont voté la grève jusqu'à lundi
inclus
certains iront manifester dimanche à
paris